All That Remains Unknown about
Kepler-22b
for starters we still don't really know
what gravity is like there it could be
twice as strong as our planets if that
was the case a 10 kilogram sack of
potatoes would now weigh 20 kilograms
and your body would also factor into the
mix well good luck suddenly dealing with
150 kilograms of you and just for safety
settlers such as yourself would need to
bulk up really bulk up
only through intense strength training
would you increase your chances of being
able to walk on Kepler-22b and once you
got jacked on Earth you'd have to figure
out ways to preserve that muscle through
all
635 years of light speed travel